bonjour à toutes et à tous je sais pas
si je suis à nuire et par mes collègues
en tout cas je suis bien là quand
l'équipe organisatrice m'a d'abord
invité pour venir vous parler
aujourd'hui j'ai eu une réaction un peu
mitigé d'un côté j'étais enthousiaste
parce que comment refuser une telle
tribune d'avoir un public aussi averti
et en même temps easy going mais
également gérer un peu de j'étais un peu
sceptique parce que qu'est-ce qu'un
enseignant chercheur modestes comme moi
peut bien faire dans une conférence ted
et puis que dire elle est plus austère
de mes collègues je pratique une
discipline qui s'appelle la science
politique
c'est une discipline où la scientificité
régulièrement remis remise en cause par
les plus austères de nos collègues
justement parce que beaucoup d'autres
collègues interviennent régulièrement
dans les médias et souvent il faut bien
le reconnaître pour ne rien dire mais je
pratique ou en tout cas je crois à ce
que certains appellent la sociologie
public où la science politique publique
si vous voulez la sociologie public
c'est non pas accumuler des
connaissances la connaissance pour la
connaissance
j'ai raté mon introduction mais c'est
pas grave on va vous voulez vous dire
tout à l'heure que je n'avais pas grand
chose à faire
chez talent parce que je n'avais pas
traverser les océans à d'autres requins
je n'avais pas non plus april2010
allègue que compte le continent africain
et puis je ne suis l'auteur de qu'une
invention originale qui mérita le prix
nobel
donc je reprends la sociologie public
est ce que c'est à sa survie public
c'est produire des connaissances mais
c'est surtout les faire circuler les
faire sortir
de l'univers académique des frontières
de l'université il ya plusieurs manières
de le faire il ya l'enseignement bien
sûr il ya aussi des conférences comme
comme aujourd'hui
l'intérêt de cette régie publique
c'est de montrer et de diffuser les
acquis des sens social qu'est ce que ces
questions sociales ce sont des sciences
qui permettent à croire d'accroître
pardon le sens critique des individus
elle poursuit ce projet très ambitieux
pourquoi parce qu'elle ne produit pas
n'importe quel type de connaissances les
connaissances produites par les
socialistes sont fondées sur des
hypothèses une problématique c'est que
c'est un terme que vous met à
fonctionner ici à sciences po il y a
également bien évidemment un
investissement sur un terrain de
recherche
et puis il ya des résultats et cette
connaissance que l'on produit de son but
il est l' inverse de toutes ces
connaissances qui pullulent sur les
réseaux sociaux et qui relèvent du
fast-food king ou de la pensée molle ou
bien du sens du sens commun
pourquoi je vous dis cela parce que je
crois que nous vivons dans un monde
paradoxal d'un côté comme je disais nous
sommes submergés d'informations de
connaissances diverses et variées et de
fait tous les jours nous en apprenons de
nouvelles hier par exemple en préparant
cette intervention jour où ma page yahoo
et j'apprends que de nouveaux indices de
nouveaux éléments sur un candidat à la
présidentielle de la république vont
être rapidement et bientôt livrer au
public
j'apprends aussi que beyoncé grande
nouvelle à nous annoncer ou encore ou
encore que l'om cherche son seul à thann
et puis en un clic on peut avoir accès
sans attendre aux 15 scènes les plus
torrides du cinéma mondial
mais nous vivons dans un monde paradoxal
parce que d'un côté il ya toutes les
informations qu'on peuvent accumuler
sans problème et puis de l'autre il me
semble et ça va être l'objet de mon
intervention je crois que nous sommes
tous enclins à ce que j'appellerais le
refus de savoir où le déni même d'une
certaine
réalité car ses connaissances que nous
engrangeons que nous gobons il est rare
que nous les ayons hérarchie ions il est
rare aussi que nous trouvions dans celle
ci
celle qui nous font avancer celles qui
sont les plus utiles à nous mêmes mais
aussi je veux dire à la société et ce
refus de savoir ce déni de savoir est
plus répandu qu'on ne pense
c'est pour ça que la formule donc ça
c'est les rues dit ça ce sont les
réseaux sociaux mais ça c'est aux races
c'est pour ça que la formule de race
sapere aude et oser savoir est si belle
bien sûr je me suis demandée
[Musique]
des vues si tel n'avait pas inversée
sens des mots savoir oser faisait plus
t'aide à mon avis mais c'est sans doute
le signe que j'avais des préjugés osé
savoir oser savoir car le savoir le
savoir mérite suppose un effort voire de
l'audace voir aussi une rupture avec
notre confort intellectuel les sens
social justement ont pour mission de
lutter contre le refus de savoir
je pourrais vous donner mille exemples
qui illustrerait vous les connaissez la
sociologie par exemple de l'éducation a
montré que la démocratisation
d'enseignement n'avait pas amoindri les
inégalités et les avait renforcées par
exemple les grandes écoles notamment en
sont lundi mais je ne veux pas faire ça
ici
karski et m'a dit magique presque
magnifique quand on pratique les sens
social c'est que au fond on peut
travailler un petit peu surtout dès lors
qu'on arrive à construire le
questionnement que l'on propose et moi
j'ai voulu travailler justement sur le
déni lui-même d'où vient ce refus de
savoir comment est-il alimenter et
quelle forme
il prend alors je vais vous donner un
exemple tiré de mes recherches je trouve
que je pratique la sociologie politique
des changements de régime c'est à dire
que je m'intéresse au processus de
démocratisation vos épisodes
révolutionnaires et puis à ce qui se
produit par la suite pendant très
longtemps j'ai travaillé sur ce
magnifique pays qu'est la pologne après
la chute du communisme et depuis six ans
j'ai choisi de transgresser un peu la
frontière entre les aires culturelles n
intéressait à la tunisie dans le
contexte même de du soulèvement
comment c'est un 17 décembre 2010 à sidi
bouzid par l'immolation de mohamed
bouazizi et dont l'une des issues
immédiate ce n'est pas la seule a été le
départ de ben ali
il banalise sur fond mauve parce que le
move et et sa couleur fétiche
alors dans ce travail je m'intéresse un
élément très spécifique ce sont les
élites et les élites pas n'importe
lesquels je m'intéresse à la manière
dont les cadres de l'ancien régime se
réinvestissent ou non après la
révolution au fond qu'est-ce qu'une
révolution fait au vaincu d'une
révolution assez vaincu disqualifié par
l'histoire et dans le cadre de ce
travail j'ai pu travailler sur le déni
parce que justement j'ai pratiqué la
méthode de l'entretien on fait beaucoup
d'entretiens avec dans un cadre des
ministres députés des gouverneurs des
ambassadeurs 22 premier ministre de
l'époque de ben ali et j'ai été
interrogé sur des questions qui à mon
avis sont importantes et question des
droits de l'homme n'est pas sans savoir
qu'en tunisie existe une instance vérité
l'unité qui a été mise en place dans le
cas de la justice transitionnelle et qui
vise à faire la lumière sur les crimes
du passé
dans le cadre de cette instance vérité
et dignité des auditions publiques ont
été organisées et beaucoup de victimes
de l'ancien régime ont pu témoigner est
présentée au public
cette épreuve se transmet à la
télévision en direct les abus dont ils
ont été les victimes
la torture par exemple était une
pratique courante en tunisie
parmi les soixante mille dossiers que
l'instance vérité et dignité a
enregistré dix mille concernent des cas
de torture et on peut supposer que tous
ceux qui en ont été victimes de ne pas
ne se sont pas présentés dans le cadre
de la justice transitionnelle
alors j'ai voulu savoir ce que les
figures du régime précédent du régime
déchu en pensez est ce que il avait des
doutes des regrets voire même des
sentiments de responsabilité voire même
de culpabilité alors j'ai pratiqué ces
entretiens en étant ni juge ni
journaliste pour comprendre le discours
qu'ils allaient me donner et contre
toute attente non seulement très très
peu d'entre eux voire aucun d'entre eux
ne reconnaissait une espèce forme
quelques unes quelques une forme de
responsabilité mais en plus il nier les
faits alors quelles sont les formes de
ce dernier j'ai voulu restituer donc les
différentes manières du d
et je me suis appuyé sur un ouvrage que
vous connaissez peut-être qu'ils
s'appellent states of dynario dans
lequel l'auteur distingue trois types de
dénis le déni littérale le déni
interprétatif le déni d'implication des
néo libéral cela n'a pas eu lieu
en vo de la torture par exemple alors
j'ai un cas d'un ancien premier ministre
qui me dit vous savez en entendez parler
mais c'était tellement exagéré qu'on y
croyait guère le déni interprétatif cela
veut dire oui c'est vrai on reconnaît
les faits salhab cela a bien eu lieu
mais ce n'est pas ce que vous pensez
alors un exemple de dénis interprétatif
c'est l'idée de minimiser le crime ou
bien de dire que au fond il est
justifiable dès lors qu'on poursuit un
objectif plus noble par exemple lutter
contre l'islamisme qui a été l'argument
phare des cadres de ce régime de ben ali
et qui justifiait du coût des exactions
contre les droits de l'homme pour faire
éclore cette plante que cette belle
plante que la démocratie il faut d'abord
savoir désherber me dit un ancien cadre
du parti par ailleurs jardinier alors
troisième forme de déni le beignet
d'implication si le plus répandu c'est
de dire oui c'est vrai la torture et
bien existé oui c'est vrai j'ai tout à
fait ce que vous croyez c'est bien la
torture mais je n'y suis pour rien un
ancien cadre par exemple du parti me dit
vous savez moi je n'étais pas dans
l'exécutif alors c'est vrai j'ai soutenu
le régime précédent
j'ai fait des discours je me suis
baladée dans tout le pays mais je n'ai
jamais mis je n'ai jamais pris de
décision je n'ai jamais signé de loi ou
de décret et je n'ai jamais donné
d'ordre de ce type alors je vais voir un
ancien ministre qui se départit
l'exécutif sa ministre me dit vous savez
oui c'est vrai j'ai participé à ces
gouvernements mais j'étais clean comme
ministre de l'éducation
alors on peut me reprocher la baisse du
niveau scolaire mais en aucun cas le
fait que la torture et pu être une
pratique
je vais voir un ancien mise de
l'intérieur après tout n'est-il pas le
chef de la police et lui me dit
vous savez sous ben ali la répression
avec l'orchestré depuis carthage donc
c'est le président ben ali qui prenait
les décisions
moi je n'ai absolument rien à voir avec
toute cette histoire
alors j'ai voulu comprendre d'où
venaient ces différents types de
rhétorique
j'ai rejeté des explications qui
n'apparaissait trop simple l'idée d'une
universalité du déni au motif qu'on le
retrouve dans notre contexte analogues
l'idée aussi d'une approche d'une
approche
l'idée est venue d'une approche plus
psychologique ou psychanalytique qui met
en avant la notion de personnalité
autoritaire il me semble hélas encore
que ça ne convenait pas et puis dernière
explication celle d'une spécificité
culturelle cette idée galvaudait selon
laquelle les sociétés arabes sont
rétives à la démocratie
rétive aux droits de l'homme et que ce
sont des sociétés
on va très très bien par cet exemple
pictural orientaliste ce sont des
sociétés de violence intrinsèque
alors j'ai voulu l'expliqué différemment
ce déni en mettant en avant trois ou
quatre mêmes facteurs qui me semblait
beaucoup plus significatif
d'abord tout simplement parce que les
cadets l'ancien régime ont intérêt à
nier ils sont toujours susceptibles
d'être poursuivis par la justice
deuxièmement parce que l'histoire de la
répression n'est pas encore écrite c'est
tout l'intérêt d'ailleurs de faire des
sciences sociales ou de l'histoire il
est facile à quelqu'un de nier les
réalités dès lors qu'elles n'ont pas
encore été objective et dans des textes
des publications suffisamment reconnue
par tout le monde
on peut donc faire allègrement du
révisionnisme historique dans le
contexte tunisien d'aujourd'hui et puis
3-1 facteur si le contexte eux mêmes des
entretiens réalisés ces entretiens
permettent des jeux avec la langue c'est
hannah arendt lorsqu'elle est travaillé
sur le procès eichmann qui montrait que
à coups de clichy clichés au fond visant
ou de règles de langage en fait l'accusé
pouvait se défendre en mobilisant
justement tout ce que le langage permet
comme potentialités d'abord 2
d'exprimer un certain nombre d'idées et
puis dernièrement parce qu'il me semble
mais l'enquêté partager une propriété
sociale particulière ce sont tous des
cadres d'une élite politico
administratives qui revendique la
paternité de la modernisation du pays
qui est en fait une élite sûre
d'elle-même
peu encline à l'autocritique et dont
l'économie morale qu'on dit consiste
justement et conduit à justifier des
choses que par ailleurs on retrouverait
injustifiable pourquoi est ce que je
faisais raconter tout cela est bien
parce qu'il me semble que nous sommes au
delà des cas de l'ancien régime d'un
pays comme la tunisie
nous sommes tous sujets au refus de
savoir on n'a pas toujours conscience
mais il me semble que les analyses que
j'ai présentées sur cette autre réalité
sont valables aussi en partie pour nous
mêmes le déni littérale par exemple qui
sait aujourd'hui qui sait qu'aujourd'hui
en tunisie la torture continue d'être
pratiquée dans les commissariats
rousset de la tunisie qu'elle est
réussite exceptionnelle du monde arabe
démocratisation
qui est devenu un modèle plusieurs
organisations de la société civile ont
reçu un prix nobel
tout ça c'est très bien mais bien
évidemment mais pourquoi ces tons plus
cela que le fait que non seulement la
torture est pratiquée mais qu'en plus le
système judiciaire fait tout pour
empêcher des accusations et fait tout
pour pousser des procès vous dénie
interprétatif ne nous arrive t'il pas
parfois de donner crédit à ce qui
justifie le crime ou l'injustice au non
d'un objectif plus noble cette vieille
rhétorique de la faim qui justifierait
les moyens est ce qu'on n'est pas tous
ici et l'a amené à utiliser cet argument
et puis le déni d'implication qui à mon
avis est encore le plus le plus répandu
ne nous arrive t'il pas aussi facile
face à une situation tragique de dire
que c'est tragique mais qu'y puis-je que
puis-je y faire mais n'est-ce pas une
manière aussi de surestimer notre
impuissance à changer des choses
est ce que ce n'est pas une manière
aussi de nous des impliqués maintenant
parce que parce qu'au fond nous aussi
nous avons toutes les raisons de
pratiquer le déni c'est pour notre
intérêt d'abord pour notre confort moral
et intellectuel c'est aussi parce que
certains sujets d'indignation ne sont
pas encore entrés sur l'agenda public ne
font pas l'objet d'un traitement
médiatique et politique et donc on fait
comme s'ils n'existaient pas et puis
surtout le déni de responsabilité me
semble-t-il
il est lié aussi au fait que nous ne
sommes jamais dans les conditions d'un
entretien comme j'ai pu le faire avec
d'anciens ministres de ben ali
on n'a jamais a justifié à la fois notre
impuissance notre indifférence vis-à-vis
de crime et bien oui bien évidemment non
plus notre méconnaissance
alors comprenez moi bien j'ai dit nous
j'ai pas dis vous car mon discours n'est
pas d'un sermon c'est que ici c'est
peut-être ça fait un peu télé
évangéliste mais je n'étais absolument
pas là pour
un sermon sessouma man enclin au déni
j'ignore bien plus que je ne connais
bien évidemment il ya des réalités que
je ne saurais voir les mêmes des sujets
sur les cas je serais incapable à mon
avis de travail et vous donner je vous
montrais une image que je ne sais pas
voir ils n'arrivent pas à les regarder
et je n'arrive pas à en tirer les
conséquences
cette image très dur elle a été prise le
21 août 2013 dans la banlieue de damas
dans le quartier de la route à suite à
un massacre à l'armé chimique et les
deux petites filles sont mortes de gaza
et se jouera le 21 ou 2013 de fêter mon
anniversaire je ne sais même plus où
très très loin des réalités syrienne il
ya de fortes chances que je serais
incapable de travailler par exemple sur
les meurtres de masse ou sur des
réalités aussi effroyable mais j'essaie
par la pratique des sens social de
prendre conscience de cela de
déconstruire des saveurs ordinaire voire
inutiles et de chercher à produire des
connaissances inédite qui m'aident à
voir le monde autrement voilà où se
situe mon engagement comme chercheur
encore une fois mais aussi comme
enseignant pour diffuser ce savoir et
voilà pourquoi cette belle formule osé
savoir me touche aussi profondément
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]